diese gräueltaten sind schwere
kriegsverbrechen und die bilder sind
schrecklich das kann ein gar nicht kalt
lassen das wird auch das macht wütend
warum so viel leid über die menschen
gebracht wird und deshalb ist es richtig
dass die bundesregierung zum einen
waffen liefert aber zum anderen nimmt
auch sanktionen verhängt hat und
bundeskanzler scholz hat gestern
angekündigt dass eben diese
kriegsverbrechen aufgeklärt werden
müssen natürlich muss es konsequenzen
geben und er hat auch angekündigt dass
es eben weitere sanktionen geben soll
auch herr habeck hat das ja gestern
abend gerade im zdf bestätigt sie haben
frau schwer sich wirtschaftlich lange
auf russland gesetzt nicht zuletzt durch
die pipeline nord stream 2 war diese
politik in deutschland waren sie als
ministerpräsidentin von mecklenburg
vorpommern zu lange zu blauäugig
gegenüber russland und dem russischen
präsidenten
die pipeline nord stream 1 und auch nord
stream zwei sind ja durch die
bundesregierung verabredet worden und ja
wir sind das bundesland in dem diese
pipeline ankommen durch nord stream 2
ist kein gas geflossen und damit ist
auch kein geld verdient worden hat putin
jetzt viel geld in der ostsee versenkt
dennoch war das festhalten an nordstream
2 mit dem blick von heute ein fehler ein
fehler den auch wie in mecklenburg
vorpommern gemacht haben den auch ich
gemacht habe und deshalb ist es wichtig
ganz konkret jetzt konsequenzen zu
ziehen mecklenburg vorpommern hat die
diplomatischen kontakte die wir haben zu
unserer partnerregion wir haben ja
dialog mit unser partner region geführt
nicht nur in wirtschaft auch in
wissenschaft in kultur wir haben keinen
dialog mit putin geführt aber auch
diesen dialog haben wir abgebrochen und
mecklenburg vorpommern ist insgesamt das
bundesland was am vierzehnten platz
steht was russische wirtschaftliche
kontakte angeht also in diesem bereich
sind wir nicht so stark betroffen
dennoch ist es richtig dass das jetzt
auf eis gelegt ist und ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen
unter putin russland das auch noch
einmal aufzunehmen sind offene worte von
ihnen frau schwesig ganz kurz noch
irgendwann wird dieser krieg aber vorbei
sein
sie haben putin gerade angesprochen wie
könnte denn danach eine beziehung zu
russland aussehen
das ist eine sehr schwere frage und noch
mal unter putin russland ist das kaum
vorstellbar und gleichzeitig werden wir
in deutschland die frage beantworten
müssen wenn die idee der entspannungs
politik der viele jahre auch getragen
hat die auch die wiedervereinigung
möglich gemacht hat von der ich sehr
stark geprägt bin wenn diese idee auch
das wirtschaftlichen austausch auch mit
schwierigen staaten mit autokraten nicht
möglich ist oder gefährlich ist wie wir
heute sehen was ist unsere antwort dann
es betrifft ja auch andere länder wie
zum beispiel china und das sind
antworten die wir in deutschland
insbesondere die bundespolitik geben
muss und daran müssen wir arbeiten
aus heutiger sicht ist das zurzeit sehr
alles sehr sehr schwer vorstellbar auch
gerade angesichts dieser taten in der
tat schwer vorstellbar dass war die
ministerpräsidenten von
mecklenburg-vorpommern manuela schwesig
vielen dank